I have a meeting like at the New York
Stock Exchange later today how what am I
gonna do you know I'm always amazed
gonna be like fire style
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Ashton Kutcher you
know I'm from more than 20 years in TV
and film he's also a successful tech
entrepreneur and investor but don't
worry hasn't quit his day job quite yet
new episodes of the ranch part 7 or on
Netflix now go check it out but first
the wings of death Ashton Kutcher
welcome to the show thank you for having
me on the show I really appreciate it
I'm extremely nervous right now but I'm
not gonna talk very much
why are you nervous I don't know because
I don't know what I'm getting into here
this is a little disconcerting so I've
experienced it before it's painful are
you ready for another round I'm ready to
go I'll Rumble with you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just their classic just a classic okay
what we don't have
[Music]
that's all a little tingle on the tongue
mm-hmm not bad
flavorful but this is one okay I'm good
says he mentioned in your intro the
ranch that returned to Netflix and as a
native Iowan I know that you're no
stranger to the ranching lifestyle yeah
so when I was 13 my mom we've got into
the country and so I helped her out on
the on the ranch a little bit like
helping out with the adil and stuff like
that
the craziest thing was like when you
have like bowls that you don't want to
crop to continue to breathe they got to
cut the nuts on the bowl
you cut nuts so I've cut nuts before
that's very unpleasant to watch which
Hawkeye state specific job taught you
the most about life see I had a lot of
like very blue-collar jobs growing up I
worked in serial factory it's like
sweeping cheerio dust washed dishes in a
kitchen for a while I used to skin deer
in a butcher shop during deer season I
think the biggest thing that taught me
was like just appreciation because when
you do have a job like that that when
you get home at the end of the day you
collapse from physical exhaustion
collapsing from mental exhaustion from
like sitting in an office all day seems
easy and being an actor seems even
easier
[Music]
goodbye wing number one goodbye wing
number one on the window to Chicago red
hot jalapeno okay let's do it
see I prefer the like little leg wants
me to a little bit less messy you know
let's navigate okay that's alright so I
know that you're a football sessom from
your days playing linebacker at Deer
Creek a mainittu watching NFL playoff
games from the sidelines and Soldier
Field can you give us a story from your
days as an assistant freshman football
coach at Harvard Westlake like did you
ever have to snap a clipboard over your
knee arguing a call were you ever called
on to give a spirited halftime speech or
anything like that so when I was in high
school my uncle was my coach at one
point during a halftime speech he told
one of the other players to go sit by
the toilet because all he was a piece of
[ __ ] so that's the sort of football
spirit that I got he actually lifted me
up in full pads during a halftime speech
once you go you're wearing $1,000 worth
of equipment use it like toss me back
down so this is like the football I
don't think I harvard-westlake was like
ready for Iowa football guy so I
definitely tone things down but at one
point I gave a speech where one of the
other coaches pulled me aside and was
like a freshman like we might want to
just not we don't need to necessarily
like go that far with it so yeah
different people need different types of
motivations to perform at their highest
ability and some people that don't ever
have anyone give them a kick in the ass
need a kick in the end you can see it
you can see it on the field that's all
[Music]
we are the heartbeat pineapple now
pineapple so the sweetness should cut
down the heat a little bit mm-hmm should
when we started the show we lost track
at how many guests sitting in your seat
would look around and be like am I being
Punk'd right now you know the show it's
pop culture impact it's so obvious but
I'm curious about what you think its
influence was with how celebrity is
handled in the media like do you think
famous people have been more on their
heels ever since then so I once had like
a TMZ guy like outside of a airport like
shove a camera in my face
and he was like just asking me just
abrasive stuff I just didn't want to
talk the guy had like no interest and he
was like come on man you did punked like
you know like this is the thing and I
was like now this is like really
different than Punk'd like yes we filmed
people on Punk'd but we never aired a
single episode that a celebrity didn't
sign a waiver to say it's okay to air
this and in fact there were many cases
where I was like listen I'll show you
the final cut product if you don't like
it if you don't think it's funny we just
won't air it and then I know the stakes
for the pranks they were very high like
what's the most money you think you ever
lost either because a mark caught on to
what you were doing or because something
went haywire so usually if a mark caught
on to what we were doing we would hit
the eject button and then like keep them
bit up and then bring try to bring
somebody else into the scenario so we
didn't lose the money right
or we would keep it going on for so long
that they'd be like okay there's no way
I'm being Punk'd and then you're right
like right back on so a lot of times
someone would be like I'm being Punk'd
right now my I'm square I'm Buick Ashton
come out I'll be bug and and I would
just like okay everybody back off and
chill so that happened quite a bit but I
think the most amount we lost was like
$300,000 on amber ball I can't remember
exactly but I want to say there was like
a special effect that was supposed to go
off that didn't go off and we couldn't
get it to trigger and there was no way
to do it and so we had it just like we
had to just pull
[Music]
okay well the thing is that's a really
good one um I'm getting that there you
go
free sponsorship we actually make that
one Ashton thanks all you do yeah that's
all you mm-hmm
Congrats thank you so far so as someone
who scaled the heights of entertainment
and also founded their own venture
capital firm I think you're uniquely
qualified to weigh in on this window
it's Abydos the shows have the juice is
coming I like the flow where are pitch
meetings more likely to be parodies of
themselves in Hollywood or in Silicon
Valley oh that's a great question I
think Silicon Valley they talk about
this the elevator pitch yeah you'll
literally get in an elevator so it's
like I just got to tell you about my
company I just got to tell you about me
coming let me just tell you about my
company I have to tell you about my
company and you're like dude I'm gonna
get off of this thing in like one minute
so you got a minute and you've already
wasted 20 seconds saying let me tell you
about my company you better start
telling me about the company and it's
usually like some guy with like a hoodie
and I mean it's like bro it's the
archetype that you expect what's easier
internal math for you passing on an
investment or passing on a script
passing a script with a script I always
know what I want to do it immediately
sometimes you can like love the idea of
a company but the math just doesn't work
and so you actually have to like do the
architecture of the math and then
finally when is overnight success more
of a curse in entertainment or in tact
Oh entertainment for sure even now if
the founders of those companies they
don't actually get the capital for all
the work that they've done until the
company either has an exit event goes
public or they pull money off the cap
table so it's not like they're sitting
like burning through millions of dollars
their company can be worth billions but
they could maybe still be living
one bedroom apartment but it was like an
entertainment people get the money right
now and they get the fame right now and
so it's like the combo of money and fame
can be really really dangerous
[Music]
let's go yellow one yeah this is yellow
[Music]
alright Ashton we have a crane segment
on our show called explain that Graham
where do a deep dive on our guest
Instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context and here in season 10
we're doing it big
we have retired the laptop when we are
now going off monitors camera guy bill
says there will be no hiccups so we have
our best man on it
where's camera guy bill right there
what's up camera guy bill which one
shirts a mid-summer Oh have you seen
midsole Martin yeah first things first
it's you courtside at Staples Center
talking to Kobe do you remember this
moment yeah specifically I think I was
giving him a hard time because I would
see I was talking about like how it
feels to be getting older okay because
he was like he was like man I can't keep
up with these kids they're like going
that was I think it was early in the
season he's like all over the boy and I
was like yeah we're getting older bud so
this is yeah we're getting older bud
that's the caption is it true that you
savagely heckled Gary Payton so bad one
time that he returned the trash talk yes
I was in I think those same seeds and I
said I was like giving him a really
really hard time he was like why'd you
shut up and eat a hot dog and I was like
listen I'm under his skin I've already
won
Diddy Party stories they're our favorite
genre of anecdote if I relive one yeah
Wow okay I've got a lot I can't tell I
can't feel that one either I mean like
actually cycling through them there was
one moment so it's not really a party
story but our relationship is really
bizarre so it started over punked cuz
yes like yo don't [ __ ] you can't Punk me
and I was like I don't want to tell you
everybody's on the table
like not me I'm off the table and so
that started our conversation we became
fast friends
and we used to hang out watch football
together really well and he came over
and I was like I'm going for a run he's
like oh I'll go for a run with you so he
comes over to go for a run about halfway
through the run he's like yo I'm running
out of gas right now but we had like
paparazzi all around us at the time he's
like you got to slow down and but make
it look like you're not slowing down cuz
he had I don't want to look like I'm not
gonna be able to finish this thing and
he was losing it right like he was like
me right now with the wings and the heat
starting to kick up and he's like and
weave so we finished out the run and
then he he was so upset over the fact
that he got skunked on this run that
year he decided to run the New York
Marathon and so we just started
immediately training for the New York
Marathon
I like that Penn's attack well he just
can't lose even when he's that close to
humility that like it becomes a driver
and so then he went out and ran the New
York Marathon here you are playing Steve
Jobs and the Steve Jobs biopic why huh
why is it a bad idea to do the Steve
Jobs fruitarian diet oh my god I this is
the craziest thing so I'm studying the
character and there was this book that
he had read that he got when he was in
India about like the healing properties
of fruitarian diet listen but I was just
sort of studying like his eating habits
and his behaviors and was told that he
drank a lot of carrot juice and part of
it he kind of always had like an orange
color to his skin because he drank this
Odwalla carrot juice and I was like well
if I'm playing the character I'll didn't
drink carrot juice odd that we're just
showing since my skin so I started just
drinking carrot juice like non-stop like
all day long two weeks before we went to
start shooting and wholesome Robins like
I had this like pain in my back and
through the night it got worse and worse
and worse and worse and worse and I
ended up in the hospital on like the
maximum dose of dilaudid because I've
got like my pancreas was like crazy out
of whack and then I'm getting freaked
out I'm like oh my god I've become Steve
Jobs she died of a pancreas
like I'm this is like the ghost of Steve
Jobs it's like taking over my bank I'm
freaking out and just turns out like it
was the carrot juice that was causing
this like crazy pancreatitis
so don't drink too much carrot juice
that's a moralist story here we go
fire fire so the tech world it's known
for disruptive thinking and bold
proclamations so now that we have a tech
power player here what I want to do is
bounce a few big ideas of the future off
of you and I'm just curious if you agree
or disagree okay okay this first one is
from former Facebook president Sean
Parker yeah I believe in the future
privacy will be the new celebrity yeah I
was there when he said that he and I
were doing an interview together he said
in the future privacy will be the new
celebrity I think he's right like I have
an app in my phone in my pocket right
now it's like a big app that's a facial
recognition app I can hold it up to
anybody's face here and like fine
exactly who you are what internet
accounts are on what they look like
what's terrifying here it comes yeah
there it is I have like some after
saliva happening really this next one is
from Frank eeing the CEO of allied East
for low glow as an industry video gaming
is already bigger than music and movies
combined these sports we start over
again are your a thing all right as an
industry in my ears as an industry you
know video gaming is already bigger than
music and movies combined yeah eSports
will be the biggest format of
entertainment yes that's by this live
gaming stuff is like just absolutely
insane there are more people watch like
the well as there was like the League of
Legends finale than watch the Super Bowl
it's very clearly happening alright this
next one is from Elon Musk I think the
most important thing is to create a
self-sustaining city on Mars that's I
think the critical thing for maximizing
the life of humanity yeah I don't know
if I agreed necessarily with that whole
thesis and I like you on I like a lot of
the things that he thinks about and says
but the notion is is that
for the survival of the species we need
to be able to get off the planet right
and so the first step to get off the
planet is get to the next nearest planet
but don't we want to see like some sense
that we can actually get to a hospitable
planet when bays Ellis will say the same
thing a lot of it's like parroting some
of the stuff that you'll onset
functionally speaking it's hard to
believe that we're gonna have enough
energy for people's consumption of
energy over time on this planet so we
may well want to be able to get energy
on other planets and finally you got to
be pretty desperate to make it with a
robot that's from Homer Simpson uh-huh
it's just frog and I disagree I want my
eyes burning now Did you touch my brain
I think it touched my eye no now I have
a knife
we had a powwow I know you haven't all
about it I'm gonna be okay happens and
it okay I'm just I don't have anything
to wipe my anything on it yet have this
is crazy
here comes down here comes dumb aah with
a fresh one yeah here let's trade that
guy out oh oh oh with you
thank you we offer more than there's
water in milk urine everything is full
service this is lovely by the way like
one of the best interview questions I
had a long time yeah I feel like we
still have some time to go you know I
can blow it here okay feel free
Diddy parties stories man that was like
some weird memory lane yeah
what kind of pepper are we getting to do
if it doesn't tip I think it's a ghost
and Reapers adjust I just had a return
there was a return just said return to
sender right there I haven't go I have a
meeting like at the New York Stock
Exchange later today how what am I gonna
do you know I'm always amazing maybe
like fire sale
holy smokes okay let's go meeting all
right that's more my wheelhouse
mm-hmm what's the one so know that you
were an early adopter to Twitter if I
have my information right you're even
the first users to pass a million
followers I'm in the Guinness Book of
World Records I just found that out
today and and since that excited I have
a word in the Webster's dictionary
Punk'd but I'm in the Guinness Book of
World Records I think that's pretty cool
I'm humbled I'm on board by the fact
that that happens somehow it is it and
say life like I can't believe it like
guys boils my life as a kid if you told
myself as a kid though I'm gonna shut up
you go ahead as one of the first
celebrities to fully embrace social
media do you think I'm a shift level
increasingly there's this pressure to
build this like cult of personality to
help market or make viable whatever
project is being made there are actors
that do very very well by being very
very well known as who and how they are
in their daily lives if I were to do my
career differently I think I would have
like held Who I am and how I am in my
personal life way closer to the vest so
that I had more versatility in the
characters that I play because sometimes
I'll be playing a character people like
they just call [ __ ] instantly
because they know who and how I am and
therefore they can't buy into me they
can't like make the the imagination leap
into me as that character and I think
there are ton of really really great
actors that do that really well like
Gary Oldman you tell me how Gary Oldman
is in real life and I'll give you a
dollar
Joaquin Phoenix that's another like how
is Joaquin in real life you don't know
but you know that these characters that
he plays are just like you know all over
the map like Ryan Gosling I think it's
done a really good job
but that's kind of always been the case
you've always had like you know Tom
Cruise's and people that were like
extraordinarily well known for who and
how they were and then the characters
that they play were really similar to
that and so you could sort of see them
in the character and then you've had
actors that are like these hard
character actors that are just outside
of themselves and don't want to be known
by the public and I think boats still
exist ah mother Mary who are Steve
Carell okay here we go oh look at you
casually drinking your water like a
ninja and ninja he is a sneaking yeah in
the shadows I saw that I'm the audience
saw it as well because I've been exposed
over here Oh Lord what's really turning
guys I haven't eaten yet today this is
my first bite Oh
[Music]
return to sender address unknown the
bomb no such number
keep it off the lips I'm seeing you
that don't even taste like food yeah
that's what we came here for yes
endorphins [ __ ] you five hours of sleep
your energy shots I'm good baby we are
up ha
do people still stop you on the street
for dude sweet conversations or is that
tailed out over sweet sweet sweet and
Dan and then no no and then no and then
the New York Times once reported that
you were up to five trucker hats in a
single episode of Punk'd confirm or deny
on that I probably I just throw them all
out yesterday like two days ago the
house I just tossed the butcher the
trucker I still had them all along with
my entire wardrobe from the 70 show is
it true you once got fired from a
Cameron Crowe movie uh fired
yeah I'll say fired sure he originally
wanted Orlando Bloom for Elizabethtown
and then when Lena bloom was working on
Ridley Scott picture and then it wasn't
available and so I went in I auditioned
you cast me and then we started working
on it and I think he wanted to like see
the character in rehearsals like all the
way and I just I probably wasn't like
disappoint enough as an actor to get
myself to a point where I was like able
to do that show it to him in a way that
he felt comfortable at a certain point
we just kind of agreed that like it
wasn't working out more him than me but
also I found out at the same time that
Orlando Bloom had just become available
right when he decided let me go so I
think he had like a nice aim thing that
he could land on Oh smokes
okay can I get another one of these
please yep this is a different because I
don't want to wipe my face with that
burning whatever that thing isn't hi hi
puppy
thanks Dale
[Music]
why do I keep saying these random things
you know we have to do what we have to
do to cope in these situations you know
oh gosh anyway to get through it
Oh Mila Kunis I love you if I don't make
it out of this honey I take care of the
children so this next one isn't burn
after eating
that's the worst name burn after eating
that's a wonderful name Venezuela
okay let's go dancin on it
all right so most of the people watching
right here that recognize you from your
many movies and TV shows but you've also
executive-produced a fair number of
reality TV shows including the wildly
underrated adventures in Hollywood what
can you give us that was that three 6
mafia yeah yeah where they were living
though the wildly underrated woods what
through me can you give us one how the
sausage is made trade secret when it
comes to reality TV I'm I'm like the
biggest bachelor fan in the world I love
that show I think bachelor in paradise
is like unbelievable but I think it's
just like this extraordinary look at
like humanity in a different way that I
don't get to see every day
and it's sort of like compresses human
decision-making into this like pressure
cooker where you watch people have to
like consistently constantly make these
decisions and choices the key is is like
constructing a show where the functional
characters of this show have to make
high-pressure decisions at every act
break it must have been a big deal for
you then to make a cameo on rachels
season of The Bachelorette I was helpful
so my wife and I are we go on a date
like every Wednesday we go we have like
date night we love this show we watch it
all the time we actually just want to
come watch them tape but then they were
like hey can you come on really sure and
then you shot that segment at Malibu
wines do you get a chance to feed
Stanley the giraffe while you were there
the crooked neck drop
I saw the drop it and feed it why are
you shaking the bottle
all right so this is the last dab we
call it the last AB because it's
tradition around here to put a little
extra on the last wing try not to be as
aggressive with the poor as I was
should you be brave enough to go there
you don't have to if you don't want comp
down relax
okay feel better I think you're getting
a little I mean you know when you get to
the finish line you know I can't feel my
nose very deliberate where you sit try
not to be as aggressive on the pores
what you were so I'm trying not to be as
aggressive on the pore I'm listening I'm
taking all the obstruction tags look at
that puts things in perspective it all
right Aston Kutcher here we are at the
end of our ride down the spicy wing
gauntlet and we've hit on a lot of the
Ashton Kutcher greatest hits but there's
one deep cut that we've missed and
that's that you're a biochemical
engineering major over at the University
of Iowa that's right
so I'm gonna take it back to those
classroom days can you do your best with
the heat going through you yeah to
explain punnett squares to the Internet
look spike punnett squares yeah sure
okay so punnett squares are basically a
a it's it's a way to solve for dominant
and recessive traits right genetically
right we're gonna make our little four
quadrants square okay Big B Brown little
B blue okay the only way to have blue
eyes is to have two little bees and when
the other parent could have had brown
eyes but been a carrier for the
recessive trait of blue eyes so that so
mom would be little B little B so now
we're gonna determine each one of these
box holds a 25% likelihood of the
offspring having that color of eyes my
nose is running
give me a moment as soon as you can see
if this offspring which is one of the
potential offspring has a big beat and a
little beat they will have brown eyes
this offspring would have a big be a
little B and have brown eyes dual
recessive dominant recessive having a
recessive offspring in education from
Ashton Kutcher and look at you my man
ten chicken wings up ten chicken wings
down and still in plenty of time for
your meeting over on Wall Street oh now
there's no range was rough
look at him but then we just send out
didn't we we send out I got to know a
lot about shooting it about the pain of
others and all the sudden ours seem like
nothing didn't it that's a gratitude for
the world you and I exactly true and the
education continues now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you Ashton Kutcher this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life
we're clog or anything like that what
are you talking about sighs oh the ranch
is out on Netflix right now so you can
check out the ranch on Netflix oh if you
want to text me you can just hit me up
my number is three one nine five one
nine zero five seven six that's an
actual number you can text me I'll try
to hit you back if I have time otherwise
I keep you up on what else is going on
in the world you'll be all right after
this it'll be okay he's out a couple
ways we said a couple ways any other
beer do we have any beer for Ashton what
is up spice lards camera guy bill here I
know we've retired the laptop this
season and you all miss me but I want
you to know that I'm still hard at work
behind the camera if you like today's
episode it would mean a lot to me and
the rest of the hot ones crew to give us
a little like or a little subscribe it
would really mean a lot this camera guy
bill here saying it's good to be a
camera guy bill
you